>>> BREAKING NEWS, WE ARE
LEARNING NEW DETAILS ABOUT THE
INJURIES SUFFERED BY ACCLAIMED
AUTHOR, SALMAN RUSHDIE AFTER A
MAN RUSHED ON STAGE AND BEGAN
STABBING HIM MULTIPLE TIMES.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE VIDEO,
IT'S VERY ALARMING.
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE RUSHING
ON STAGE TO PULL THE ASSAILANT
AWAY AND HELP RUSHDIE.
POLO SANDOVAL HAS MORE ON ALL OF
THIS.
THERE'S NEW INFORMATION COMING
IN.
WHAT'S THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: THIS NEW
INFORMATION HELPS PAINT A
CLEANER PICTURE WHEN IT COMES TO
JUST THE VIOLENT NATURE OF THE
ATTACK THAT THE WORLD WITNESSED
YESTERDAY AS SALMAN RUSHDIE WAS
GETTING PREPARED TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT LECTURE EVENT.
SO BRAND NEW DETAILS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE NICKY BROWN WHO'S
REPORTING FROM INSIDE A
COURTHOUSE TELLING US MORE ABOUT
THE EXTENT OF HIS INJURIES.
PROSECUTORS THAT ARE OVERSEEING
CHARGES AGAINST THE 24-YEAR-OLD
SUSPECT FROM NEW JERSEY BELIEVED
TO BE RESPONSIBLE NOW TELLING US
THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT THE
75-YEAR-OLD WAS STABBED AT LEAST
THREE TIMES IN THE NECK, THREE
STAB WOUNDS TO THE NECK, FOUR TO
HIS STOMACH, A PUNCTURE WOUND TO
HIS RIGHT EYE, WHICH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAYS HE MAY
LOSE BECAUSE OF THE EXTENT OF
THE INJURIES AND THE DAMAGES
THERE, AND A LACERATION TO HIS
SIDE AS WELL.
SO AGAIN, THIS REALLY PAINTS AN
EVEN CLEARER PICTURE OF JUST THE
EXTENT OF THE INJURIES AND THE
EXTENT OF THE VIOLENCE WE SAW
PLAY OUT YESTERDAY.
AS FOR THE SUSPECT, HADI MATAR,
HE HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED BY NEW
YORK STATE POLICE AS A
24-YEAR-OLD NEW JERSEY MAN.
HE WAS IMMEDIATELY APPREHENDED
BY AUTHORITIES THAT WERE ON THE
SCENE.
HE DID ENTER A NOT GUILTY PLEA
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE TWO
CHARGES THAT WERE FILED AGAINST
HIM BY PROSECUTORS OF
SECOND-DEGREE ATTEMPTED MURDER
AS WELL AS ASSAULT.
NOW THE BIG QUESTION THAT
REMAINS, NOT JUST WHERE THE
ATTACK HAPPENED WHICH IS ABOUT
40 MILES EAST OF WHERE WE ARE,
BUT ALSO HERE IN ERIE,
PENNSYLVANIA, WHICH IS THE
MEDICAL FACILITY HERE THAT
AUTHORITIES HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
THE LOCATION WHERE THE
75-YEAR-OLD CELEBRATED AUTHOR IS
BEING TREATED FOR HIS INJURIES.
THE BIG QUESTION IS THE MOTIVE.
CERTAINLY NO SECRET THAT HE HAD
BEEN LIVING UNDER THE CONSTANT
THREAT OF DEATH AFTER THE
PUBLICATION OF "THE SATANIC
VERSES," A PUBLICATION THAT LED
TO THE RELIGIOUS DECREE THAT WAS
ISSUED BY IRANIAN OFFICIALS
CALLING FOR THE DEATH OF AUTHOR,
AND IT WAS ONE THAT WAS
BASICALLY REAFFIRMED AS RECENTLY
AS 2017.
ADDING TO THAT, WHAT WE ARE
GETTING IN TERMS OF THE
HEADLINES FROM THE MORE HARD
LINE CONSERVATIVE NEWSPAPERS IN
IRAN THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY
CELEBRATING THIS GRIZZLY ATTACK
THAT WE SAW PLAYING OUT WHILE
YOU AT THE SAME TIME HAVE
LEADERS HERE IN THE WEST THAT
ARE STRONGLY CONDEMNING IT,
DESCRIBING IT AS AN ATTACK ON
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION, AND
REALLY WHAT YOU'RE GETTING NOT
JUST FROM OFFICIALS, INCLUDING A
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER IN
WASHINGTON, CALLING THIS AN
APPALLING ATTACK HOPING HE'S
ABLE TO FIGHT THROUGH THE EXTENT
OF HIS INJURIES.
BASED ON THE BRAND NEW
REPORTING, PAINTS A VERY
DISTURBING, VERY VIOLENT PICTURE
OF WHAT PLAYED OUT YESTERDAY
MORNING ON THAT STAGE.
JIM.
>> YEAH, IT IS SUCH A DISTURBING
CASE.
POLO SANDOVAL, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS REACTED TO
THE ATTACK ON SALMAN RUSHDIE,
JUST RELEASED A STATEMENT OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
PRESIDENT WRITES IN PART, SALMAN
RUSHDIE, WITH HIS UNMATCHED
SENSE OF STORY, STANDS FOR
ESSENTIAL UNIVERSAL IDEALS,
TRUTH, COURAGE, RESILIENCE, THE
ABILITY TO SHARE IDEAS WITHOUT
FEAR.
THESE ARE THE BUILDING BLOCKS OF
ANY FREE AND OPEN SOCIETY, AND
TODAY WE REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT
TO THOSE DEEPLY AMERICAN VALUES,
AND ALL THOSE THAT STAND FOR
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION.
CNN'S JUMANA JOINS ME FROM
GEORGIA.
CALLING FOR HIS DEATH FOR
DECADES, HOW IS IRAN REACTING TO
THIS ATTACK.
>> Reporter: JIM, WE'VE NOT HAD
OFFICIAL REACTION YET FROM IRAN
OR ANY MAJOR MUSLIM COUNTRY,
REALLY, I THINK.
WHEN THE NEWS BROKE YESTERDAY, I
CAN TELL YOU BEING HERE IN THIS
REGION, I THINK THERE WAS A LOT
OF SURPRISE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL THAT THE
ISSUE OF SALMAN RUSHDIE IS
SOMETHING OF THE PAST, THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT WAS IN FOCUS IN
THE LATE '80s AND THE '90s.
YOU HAVE SO MANY, ESPECIALLY THE
YOUNGER GENERATIONS WHO HAVEN'T
REALLY HEARD OF SALMAN RUSHDIE
AND THE SATANIC VERSES.
A LOT OF SURPRISE, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE SUSPECT ATTACKER WHO
WAS 24 YEARS OLD, WHO WASN'T
EVEN BORN "THE SATANIC VERSES"
WAS PUBLISHED.
ALL EYES ARE ON IRAN, A COUNTRY
SOME BLAME FOR INCITING.
WE HEARD THAT FROM THE ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER, TWEETING HIS
COUNTRY'S CONDEMNATION OF THIS
ATTACK, AND HE'S ALSO SAYING
THAT IT IS THE REGIME IN I RAN
THAT HE DESCRIBED AS AN
EXTREMIST REGIME INTO IRAN THAT
LED THE INCITEMENT FOR DECADES
AGAINST SALMAN RUSHDIE.
OF COURSE AS YOU KNOW VERY WELL,
JIM, BACK IN 1989, IT WAS
AYATOLLAH THAT ISSUED THE
DECREE, CALLING FOR THE KILLING
OF SALMAN RUSHDIE, AND THEN, YOU
KNOW, IT DID SEEM DURING THE
'90s THAT THE IRANIAN REGIME AT
THE TIME HAD SOFTENED ITS
STANCE, THAT IT MAY HAVE
BACKTRACKED ON THAT, BUT AGAIN,
2017, THE CURRENT SUPREME LEADER
SAYING THAT THIS IS STILL IN
PLACE, THAT IT IS STILL VALID.
WE'VE NOT HAD ANY OFFICIAL
REACTION FROM THE IRANIANS, WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN IS SOME REACTION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, AND THEN YOU'VE
ALSO GOT IRANIAN HARD LINE
PUBLICATIONS, A COUPLE OF
NEWSPAPERS, ONE PUBLISHING A
COLUMN TODAY, PRAISING THE
ATTACKER, DESCRIBING HIM AS A
WARRIOR, SAYING THAT HE DESERVES
A THOUSAND BRAVOS, HUNDREDS OF
GOD BLESSES THAT HIS HANDS
SHOULD BE KISSED FOR ATTACKING
RUSHDIE WHO THEY DESCRIBED AS AN
APOSATE, AND ONE THING A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WONDERING IF
THERE ARE ANY LINKS TO IRANIAN
BACKED GROUPS IN THIS REGION
THAT THIS SUSPECT MAY HAVE HAD,
AND LEBANESE MEDIA HAVE BEEN
REPORTING THAT THE SUSPECT IS
ALSO A LEBANESE NATIONAL.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT CNN HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO INDEPENDENTLY
VERIFY, BUT WE DID REACH OUT TO
THE LEBANESE GROUP, THE IRANIAN
BACKED GROUP, HEZBOLLAH TO ASK
THEM IF THEY KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS ATTACKER, IF THEY KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE ATTACK, AND
WHAT THEY SAID IS THEY KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT THIS.
ALL THEY KNOW IS WHAT THEY'VE
HEARD IN THE MEDIA AND THEY KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT THIS SUSPECT.
>> AND AS YOU WERE SAYING, THE
AGAINST RUSHDIE WAS NEVER
LIFTED.
I WOULD HAVE TO THINK IF THERE
IS A LINK, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO BE
ISSUING SOME SORT OF
CONDEMNATION SAYING SOMETHING TO
THE IRANIAN REGIME TO SAY THIS
SORT OF THING CANNOT HAPPEN ON
AMERICAN SOIL, FULL STOP.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
WAIT AND SEE HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO REACT TO THIS.
HOW THE HARD LINERS, WHO ARE IN
POWER RIGHT NOW, WHO HAVE REALLY
TRIED TO MAINTAIN THIS
ANTI-WESTERN STANCE, HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO REACT TO ALL OF THIS,
AND OF COURSE THIS IS COMING AT
A VERY CRITICAL TIME WHEN YOU'VE
GOT THE IRANIANS NEGOTIATING,
JIM, AND NUCLEAR DEAL INDIRECTLY
WITH THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE ARE IN THE FINAL PHASES
OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE
WHAT SORT OF IMPACT THIS MAY OR